the corona virus outbreak is still
spreading around the world with Iran
confirming its first two cases overnight
and there is new attention on the
outbreak aboard a cruise ship docked in
Japan 79 more cases were confirmed on
the diamond princess this morning
bringing the total there to at least 621
at the same time about 500 passengers
who tested negative were allowed to
leave that ship at the end of a two-week
quarantine and here in the US more than
300 Americans evacuated from China have
been released from their quarantine
several hundred others who returned more
recently from China and Japan remain
under observation around the country
chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook has been at the frontlines
covering other infectious disease
emergencies all around the world John
joins us now John good morning so what
lessons can we learn from these prior
cases to protect Americans now well you
know with another virus from overseas
impacting America public health
officials are trying to stay one step
ahead learning from mistakes made during
past outbreaks officials covered up the
number of SARS cases in the city does
the public understand what Zika is how
its spread how to protect themselves I
don't think so
we have to rethink Ebola infection
control when a deadly virus arrives in
the u.s. health officials follow a road
map and try to anticipate the detours
that can put the public at risk
they don't always succeed when Ebola
came to America to nurses caring for a
patient in Dallas contracted the disease
officials believe gaps in protective
equipment and unclear guidelines for
properly using it or to blame we
realized here in the United States that
we needed to enhance preparedness and
hospitals dr. angela hewlett helped
treat three ebola patients at nebraska
medicine one of the lessons from the
Ebola outbreak was that every hospital
was not prepared do you think that's
changed now I do think that that has
changed especially since the inception
of the National Ebola training and
education center that training center
now holds regular drills using protocols
strengthened after Ebola hospital
workers from across the country practice
putting on and taking off
protective gear exactly the right way
Ebola also highlighted the need for a
dedicated facility for patients showing
symptoms of infections that are
especially contagious and lethal this
brand new national quarantine center is
now monitoring 12 Americans evacuated
from China what happens behind closed
doors that could be everything from you
know ensuring that we have there the
right care providers making sure that we
have enough protective equipment with
shortages in China of medical supplies
and concerns about the worldwide supply
of drugs the CDC has already loaded up
on vital items such as medicines IVs
vaccines and ventilators our 60-minutes
team visited one of the strategic
national stockpile at a secret location
during the Zika outbreak in 2016 health
officials struggled to get the word out
to women that Zika infection during
pregnancy could cause babies to be born
with severe brain damage this time tech
companies and the World Health
Organization are collaborating to put
reputable Health Resources as the top
search results for coronavirus in an
effort to filter out misinformation
we're seeing a lot of coronavirus
mythology dr. julie gerber dean was
director of the CDC during the SARS
outbreak when china's lack of
transparency may have cost lives
she says that example is shaping how
officials are sharing information about
the corona virus one of the most
important lessons in any public health
situation is communicate people crave
information and if the CDC isn't
providing it someone else will dr.
Gerber Deng who now works at
pharmaceutical giant Merck says that
while public health experts look to
high-tech solutions in the lab to fight
the corona virus they've also learned
that protecting the public starts with a
low-tech approach we have disease
detectives who are going out and
interviewing patients interviewing their
contacts really trying to tease out clue
by clue how did they get exposed and how
fast is it spreading and there have been
a lot of lessons learned
right from SARS and from Zika and h1n1
and Ebola we have had more practice than
we hoped for but each time we have and
out
it does strengthen at least some part of
the system and overtime is getting
better and better the experts we spoke
to her especially confident about one
thing that viruses are unpredictable and
we have to be flexible enough to deal
with the unexpected right now the risk
to Americans is relatively low but this
is a fluid situation that can change and
public health officials are looking
every day for changes that could require
new approaches it said fluid situation
that's so scary because you keep hearing
about people being released and then
being diagnosed after they're released
right but still right now in the United
States 15 cases we're affected here so
we should keep that in perspective yeah
and and one of the things that I worry
about is that there's you're seeing fear
out of proportion to the facts so for
example you're seeing people Asians who
are being targeted there's prejudice
against them and that reminds me of
exactly what happened doing during Ebola
when people from Africa experience the
same sort of targeting so keep it in
perspective thank you dr. Jonathan
always good to have you at the table